abzug nach zwei jahrzehnten der
bundeswehreinsatz in afghanistan ist
geschichte 59 soldaten verloren ihr
leben
die zukunft afghanistans bleibt ungewiss
historische hitze im nordwesten der usa
und in kanada müssen die menschen
extreme temperaturen aushalten
die behörden melden über 200 tote ende
eines traums nach der em-pleite gestern
verlassen die nationalspieler das
dfb-quartier fußball deutschland liegt
am boden
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend in einen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
mittwoch wir freuen uns sehr dass sie
dabei sind kristin ist auch hier für den
sportlichen teil und dem enttäuschenden
ende einer ära christin er wohl der
abschied des bundestrainers nach 198
spielen in 15 jahren joachim löw geht
und übergibt sein amt eng verbunden
wünsche natürlich auch meinem nachfolger
dem hand flick alles alles gute und viel
erfolg und mir mein herz schlägt
weiterhin schwarz rot gold dazu gleich
mehr im sport erst zu einem ganz anderen
thema auch dort das ende einer ära der
einsatz der die bundeswehr gefordert und
geprägt hat wie wohl kein anderer ist
vorbei aber viele fragen bleiben
die letzten deutschen soldatinnen und
soldaten sind zurück aus afghanistan
eine große empfangs feier gab es nicht
fast 20 jahre lang dauerte der nato
einsatz in afghanistan das
haupteinsatzgebiet der deutschen
soldaten war der norden des landes sie
sollten für sicherheit und stabilität
sorgen auf einer fläche fast so groß wie
halb deutschland auch beim aufbau von
straßen und brunnen half die bundeswehr
und bei der ausbildung von afghanischen
sicherheitskräften
insgesamt waren über 150.000 deutsche
soldatinnen und soldaten in afghanistan
hunderte wurden dort im einsatz
verwundet 59 starben
das ende einer friedensmission aber ohne
das ist jetzt frieden gäbe
im gegenteil die taliban sind wieder auf
dem vormarsch david gebhard als die
bundeswehr maschinen am nachmittag in
deutschland landen erwartet die
rückkehrenden ein empfang ohne prunk
ohne große feierlichkeiten ohne
politikprominenz die heimkehr der
letzten soldatinnen und soldaten aus
afghanistan es ist ein nüchterner
letzter akt mission accomplished
sie haben ihren auftrag erfüllt
ich melde mich ab nicht dabei heute
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer derweil bei termin mit ihrem
amtskollegen im fernen washington
zunächst kein kamera statement zu
afghanistan lediglich ein paar sätze
schriftlich ein historisches kapitel
geht zu ende ein intensiver einsatz der
die bundeswehr gefordert und geprägt hat
bei dem sich die bundeswehr im kampf
bewährt hat ein einsatz der vor fast 20
jahren nach den terroranschlägen am 11
september begann
deutschlands sicherheit werde auch am
hindukusch verteidigt sagte einst
verteidigungsminister struck die meinung
über die bilanz des einsatzes gehen
heute auseinander
der auftrag den internationalen
terrorismus in afghanistan zu bekämpfen
und einzugrenzen ist aus meiner sicht
erfüllt und damit ist ja die aussage
dann auch bestätigt die die struck
damals getätigt hat zwölf milliarden
euro wurden in den afghanistan einsatz
insgesamt eingesetzt
und jetzt höre so sein dass man
afghanistan verlässt und im grunde
genommen den taliban im wesentlichen das
land überlässt zurückbleiben afghanische
ortskräfte und ihre familien die mit der
bundeswehr zusammen gearbeitet haben und
nun racheaktionen fürchten knapp 2.400
visa sollen erteilt worden sein ob diese
zahl reicht und wie die rettung konkret
erfolgen soll fragen bleiben offen
bundesregierung muss mehr tun was die
evakuierung von ortskräfte nach
deutschland betrifft und aussagen wie es
liegt jetzt ein visum für deutschland
vor
es gäbe zivile flüge von masar i scharif
ja das mag stimmen aber ich finde man
darf die ortskräfte die noch im land
sind nicht jetzt sich selbst überlassen
insgesamt über 150000 bundeswehrsoldaten
waren über die jahre am hindukusch 59
kehrte nie zurück ihrer wird im wald der
erinnerung bei potsdam gedacht es ist
ein einsatz der spuren hinterlassen hat
bei soldatenfamilien und dem land
insgesamt
ja also noch einige fragen noch offen
schack unterlagen nahm die
verteidigungsministerin ist heute in den
usa statt die zurückkehrenden
soldatinnen und soldaten in empfang zu
nehmen
passt das zur gesamtlage dass man nicht
so recht weiß was dieser einsatz am ende
gebracht hat und wie es jetzt
weitergehen soll
ja diese zurückhaltung die ist
tatsächlich auffällig und sie steht in
den sehr starken kontrast zur bedeutung
dieses einsatzes 20 jahre afghanistan
das hat nicht nur die haltung der
öffentlichkeit der deutschen
öffentlichkeit zu auslandseinsätzen der
bundeswehr verändert sondern es hat auch
die bundeswehr selbst zu einer anderen
gruppe gemacht und man hätte das ende
dieses historischen kapitels tatsächlich
markieren können
mit einer öffentlichen geste ohne pomp
zum beispiel eben mit einem empfang der
letzten rückkehrer durch die
verteidigungsministerium ministerin das
war aber offensichtlich nicht gewollt
was bleibt ist der eindruck dass die
deutsche öffentlichkeit und die deutsche
politik sich weiterhin sehr schwer tun
mit dem thema bundeswehr und
auslandseinsätzen und dass deutschland
aus dem afghanistan einsatz genauso
unentschlossen rausgeht wie es zu beginn
reingegangen ist
ich habe unter vielen dank für diese
analyse heute abend wie erfolgreich war
der bundeswehreinsatz darum geht es auch
ins hätte er wollte life um 19 uhr 45
wir sprechen dort mit einem veteranen
und dem nato general egon ramms der
jahre lang verantwortlich war für die
truppen in afghanistan sie können fragen
stellen und mitdiskutieren
unser nächstes thema heute abend die
sonne brennt weiter gnadenlos vom himmel
über nordamerika besonders im westen des
kontinents macht die hitze große sorgen
allein in kanada gab es deshalb wohl
schon weit über 100 tote
das land verbucht einen neuen
hitzerekord 49,5 grad in litten im
fraser valley einem tal in british
columbia
wie viel von diesem extrem wetter hängt
mit dem klimawandel zusammen auch diese
frage taucht immer wieder auf benjamin
daniel berichtet
aufgerissene straßen durch geschmorte
kabel überlastete stromnetze ein
hitzerekord nach dem anderen fordert
nordamerikas westküste heraus im
kanadischen british columbia
temperaturen von 49 5 grad im schatten
landesweiter allzeit rekord die behörden
gehen davon aus dass schon mehr als 130
menschen in verbindung mit der hitze
gestorben sind
ich denke in den letzten tagen ist uns
eine große lektion erteilt wurden die
klimakrise ist keine erfindung sie ist
sehr real
auch an der us westküste sind
mittlerweile todesfälle durch
überhitzung gemeldet worden
die behörden fordern die menschen auf
viel zu trinken und in gekühlte räume zu
gehen die von vielen gemeinden
bereitgestellt werden
die sorgen bei vielen mit denen wir
gesprochen haben sind groß dass es eine
schlimme feuer saison werden könnte denn
die brände beginnen immer früher im jahr
und auch die wasserknappheit und die
trockenheit sind jetzt schon sehr extrem
hier in kalifornien
joe biden hat mit politik und
wirtschaftsvertretern betroffener
staaten maßnahmen diskutiert um die
auswirkungen der hitze besser bekämpfen
zu können
unter anderem sollen die löhne für
feuerwehrleute angehoben werden um mehr
menschen für den beruf zu begeistern
nicht nur das risiko für brände wird
durch die extreme hitze an der westküste
hochgeschraubt es ist auch eine
unmittelbare bedrohung für die menschen
für die kinder die draußen spielen
der kampf gegen die auswirkungen der
hitze bestimmt also vielerorts weiter
das öffentliche leben so müssen in
kalifornien mehr und mehr gebiete
evakuiert werden
[Applaus]
nach deutschland hinschauen nachfragen
wenn nötig einschreiten
der bundespräsident hat heute alle dazu
aufgerufen beim thema sexuelle gewalt
gegen kinder und jugendliche haltung zu
zeigen
frank walter steinmeier traf sich heute
mit betroffenen missbrauchsbeauftragten
und fachleuten die eine ganze reihe von
vorschlägen und forderungen mitbrachten
wie kinder besser geschützt und täter
entdeckt werden können nicole diekmann
seit zwei jahren gibt es das bundesweite
hilfe telefon für opfer sexuellen
missbrauchs
seit zwei jahren helfen sie hier kindern
also den schwächsten der gesellschaft in
not oder solchen die fürchten jemanden
in not zu wissen
das sind im schnitt 600 bis 800 anrufe
von menschen die sich sorgen um ein kind
machen und es ist mehr geworden durch
corona 600 bis 800 anrufe pro monat das
netz in zeiten des logins der
brandbeschleuniger eines
gesamtgesellschaftlichen problems und
eines dringenden problems im vergangenen
jahr wurden mehr als 14.500 straftaten
des sexuellen kindesmissbrauchs
registriert gab es mehr als 1500
anzeigen wegen sexuellen missbrauchs von
schutzbefohlenen und jugendlichen und
über 18.000 angezeigte fälle von
darstellung sexuelle handlungen an und
mit kindern
tendenz stark steigend die dunkelziffer
geht als so hoch dass fachleute davon
ausgehen dass jedes zehnte kind opfer
sexueller gewalt wird der nationale rat
schlägt alarm
angst und bange machen müssen den tätern
dass sie wissen der ermittlungsdruck ist
unglaublich hoch
sie können nicht damit rechnen ihre
vermeintlich bürgerliche fassade
aufrecht zu erhalten diese wahl gewalt
die könnte verhindert werden durch einen
stärkeren politischen willen und durch
konsequenteres handeln
deshalb fordern sie konkret von der
nächsten bundesregierung unter anderem
die verbesserung von schutz und hilfe
den ausbau der forschung und
kindgerechte gerichtsverfahren etwa
durch die anhörung des kindes in seiner
gewohnten umgebung ein appell den sie
auch bei einem treffen mit dem
bundespräsidenten bekräftigten hier beim
hilfe telefon ergänzen sie diesen
katalog noch sie brauchen schlicht mehr
geld handeln und zwar möglichst schnell
das sind wir die zukunftskommission
landwirtschaft schon jetzt der künftigen
bundesregierung
zehn monate hat ein tier und
umweltschützer bauern und
wissenschaftler darüber beraten wie
landwirtschaft bei uns aussehen soll
und sie kommen zu dem schluss
nachhaltigkeit müsse in zukunft das
geschäftsmodell sein zugunsten von mehr
tierwohl und klimaschutz lebensmittel
wurden teurer
das müsse sozialpolitisch abgefedert
werden
die zahl der neuen corona infektion geht
weiter zurück das robert koch institut
meldet heute eine 7 tage incidents von
5,2 und weil die zahlen im moment so
niedrig sind läuft die sogenannte bundes
notbremse aus und wird nicht verlängert
heißt auch ab morgen müssen arbeitgeber
kein home office mehr anbieten
die wirtschaft setzt auf freiwillige
lösungen gewerkschaften dagegen fordern
klare gesetzliche regeln damit die
chancen mobile arbeit auch weiter
genutzt werden könnten
dass die korona lage besser wird aktuell
beflügelt auch den arbeitsmarkt und zwar
deutlich die bundesagentur für arbeit
meldet für juni zwei millionen 614.000
arbeitslose das sind 73 1000 weniger als
im mai
die arbeitslosenquote sinkt leicht auf
jetzt 5,7 prozent im vergleich zum juni
vor einem jahr waren 239 tausend
menschen weniger auf jobsuche
es läuft aber längst nicht alles rund
auf dem arbeitsmarkt es gibt zum
beispiel viel zu wenig auszubildende was
in der zukunft noch zum echten problem
werden dürfte
stichwort fachkräftemangel mehr als
200.000 lehrstellen sind noch unbesetzt
über die gründe jetzt isabel de la vega
beim büroartikelhersteller holz in
wiesbaden brummt das geschäft es werden
dringend auszubildende gesucht fürs büro
und die logistik unternehmerin elke holz
kathan dachte dass jetzt nach der korona
flaute ein richtiger bewerbungs boom
losgehen würde aber weit gefehlt das
überrascht uns total also wir sind
wirklich davon ausgegangen dass wir ihn
sehr viele bewerber und auch gute
bewerber und bewerberinnen bekommen aber
das dann einfach die rückmeldung so zäh
sind und dass dann eben auch die schüler
und schülerinnen ja gar nicht zum
gespräch erscheinen ohne absagen oder
eben gar nicht dann reagieren auf
rückmeldungen unsererseits da sind wir
schon sehr geschockt doch es ist oft
nicht mangelndes interesse sondern
unsicherheit bei den schülern die größer
ist als sonst weil wegen corona so viele
praktika gestrichen wurden hatten jetzt
ein praktikum und alles abgesagt das
heißt ich es zum beispiel konnte nicht
genau wissen ob ich das machen möchte
ich hab ich beim architekten beworben
ich weiß habe ich das noch machen will
ich wollte auch im krankenhaus ein
praktikum machen doch die haben alle
krankenhäuser haben mich dann immer
abgewiesen
manches einfach weiter schule noch so
ist keine andere wahl ehrlich gesagt so
ratlosigkeit auf beiden seiten junge
leute konnten nichts ausprobieren und
unternehmen finden niemanden 158 1000
jugendliche haben noch keine lehrstelle
wir suchen dich alkohols catan will
jetzt über social media noch einmal
verstärkt nach kandidaten ausschau
halten
immer mehr menschen leiden an den
spätfolgen einer kurve 19 erkrankung
deutschlands zweitgrößte krankenkasse
die barmer hat ihre daten ausgewertet
und danach waren von november bis märz
2009 100 ihrer versicherten vom post
kowitz syndrom betroffen
häufige folgen atemnot chronische
erschöpfung und angststörungen mehr als
sechs prozent aller corona patienten
waren später auch wegen post co wird
krank geschrieben
experten rechnen mit einem hohen bedarf
an reha maßnahmen
in weiten teilen deutschlands haben
heftige unwetter wieder ganze
landstriche unter wasser gesetzt
in krefeld flutete der starke regen
keller straßen und tiefgaragen mehr als
2000 notrufe gab es bei der feuerwehr
nördlich von berlin stürzten binnen
minuten zahlreiche kiefern um entwurzelt
von einer windhose die altstadt von
landshut stand teilweise unter wasser
weil die kanalisation überfordert war
und schließlich holstein vor wenigen
stunden die autobahn 21 extrem starker
regen unfall und stau und jetzt in
dieser sendung der blick zurück und nach
vorn beim deutschen fußball-nationalteam
christen der stachel sitzt richtig tief
schmerzvolle könnte das em aus kaum sein
ausgerechnet in wembley 0 2 gegen
england klar dass die enttäuschung
grenzenlos ist der frust die traurigkeit
in das selbst gesteckte ziel erneut klar
verpasst am ende der ära des
bundestrainers
als alle spieler längst das weite
gesucht haben verlässt joachim löw als
letzter das team quartier in
herzogenaurach gut behütet kaum zu
erkennen kurz zuvor hat er zumindest
noch einen kleinen einblick in sein
seelenleben gewährt er tut mir natürlich
auch leid dass wir unsere fans gestern
enttäuschend enttäuscht haben ich
übernehme natürlich auch die
verantwortung für dieses ausscheiden für
mich mit ein bisschen abstand werden
dinge bleiben unabhängig vom ein oder
anderen spiegel dinge bleiben die mir
wichtig sind für mein leben
die niederlage gegen england das abbild
eines abermals enttäuschenden turniers
der gegner abgebrüht kaltschnäuzig das
eigene team fahrlässig im umgang mit den
wenigen sich bietenden chancen
das abrupte ende einer 15 jährigen ära
unter löws nachfolger hansi flick in der
vorrunde zu gast im stadion wird aber
erst mal kein personeller umbruch
erwartet ich habe von keinem der älteren
spieler gehört dass er gesagt hat
übrigens oliver ich hab mal die hand ich
denke über rücktritt nach oder ich
wollte dir nur sagen ich werde gleich in
der presse etwas bekannt geben löw geht
aber seine verbundenheit bleibt mein
ganzes herz mit mit allem werte ich
fänds ein und wehrte die daumen drücken
emotional also kein personaler neuanfang
die haben es gehört geplant wenn fonds
in herzogenaurach
was muss die fliegt trotzdem verändern
hansi flick kommt jetzt viel arbeit zu
der auftrag an ihn ist derselbe den auch
joachim löw bekam deutschland wieder an
die weltspitze heran führen aber wir
mussten ja gestern schmerzlich
feststellen dass deutschland eben nicht
zu den besten teams europas gehört hansi
flick ist nicht bekannt als jemand der
von heute auf morgen alles umkrempelte
und keinen stein auf dem anderen lässt
aber es bekannt als jemand der spieler
integrieren kann in eine mannschaft und
das wird jetzt wichtig er muss den
jungen nachwuchstalenten wie musealer
wie harvard oder auch seine endlich eine
rolle geben in der deutschen
nationalmannschaft verbunden mit einer
spielidee die defense wieder von den
sitzen reißt viel zeit bleibt dem nicht
in 616 monaten beginnt dann die wm in
katar vielen dank sven und eine aktuelle
doku über die ära löw gibt es unter
sportstudio de sehenswert kristin
dankeschön so jetzt noch was aus der
kategorie ups es geht um einen tollen
erfolg für die griechische polizei neun
jahre nachdem sie aus einem museum
gestohlen wurden sind ein picasso und
mondrian wieder da einzigartige
kunstschätze millionenwert entsprechend
stolz wenn auch nicht besonders sensibel
präsentieren die beamten in athen ihren
fund der öffentlichkeit aber dann das
zum glück kein schaden und andererseits
die bilder lagen zuletzt in plastik
verpackt in diesem gebüsch da haben sie
das kleine missgeschick der kripo auch
noch verkraftet die lottozahlen haben
wir jetzt noch für sie und sie lauten 14
15 27 32 47 superzahl 8 weitere
gewinnzahlen wie immer auf lotto zdf de
oder im zdf text auf seite 55 7
und auch heute gibt es wieder
unwetterwarnungen des deutschen
wetterdienstes diesmal vor ergiebigem
dauerregen im nordosten präsident ali
hat gleich mehr zum wetter hier bei uns
der kollege claus kleber im heute
journal um 21.45 ab morgen freut sich
hier barbara hahlweg auf sie ich danke
für ihr interesse und wünschen allen
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wir schauen auf
den juni zurück der ja nun fast vorbei
ist 3,6 grad war zu warm und es war der
drittwärmste juni seit 1881 in
deutschland ja lokal war es natürlich
dann deutlich wärmer vier bis fünf
teilweise auch knapp darüber grad zu
warm
schauen wir auf das wetter damals mit
einem tief zu tun
das bringt innerhalb von 48 stunden
enorme regenmengen die ring mengen eines
monats und das sind gut 150 liter auf
den quadratmeter
in der nacht regnete es also norden
deutschlands weiter teils mit gewittern
durchsetzt der wind ist ruppig aus nord
elf bis 18 grad die tiefste ja und
morgen im tagesverlauf weiterer regen im
norden teilweise ergiebig nur im
südwesten lockert es auf mit
sonnenschein und dazu temperaturen 22
grad im osten deutschlands viel kühler
als die in den letzten tage im westen
und im süden teilweise unter der 20 grad
marke und die kommenden tage am freitag
im norden schauer und dann bis 24 grad
ab samstag wird es wärmer aber auch die
gewitter steigt gewittergefahr steigt
wieder an 27 grad
ein schöner abend